first things first i'm the realest
and i'm still in the murder business i
can hold you down like i'm giving
lessons right right right you should
want a bad [__] like this drop a little
pick it up just like this
cover eight cup of goose cup of crisp i
heal something worth a half a ticket on
my wrist
take another
i'm in the fast lane
from l.a to tokyo there's no road from
la to tokyo
i'm so fancy
can't you taste this gold don't put gold
in your mouth it's dirty i'm so fancy
really beautiful that's it baby i do
this i thought that you knew this can't
handle no haters and honestly
and my flow [__] they speak it
departed swagger on super i guess
i thought
you already
la know tokyo
i'm so fancy says
get drunk on the minibar
make the phone call
feel so good get it what i want
keep on turning
it don't give up
got the whole world asking how does it
have girl hands off don't touch that
look at that i bet you wishing you could
touch that
just the way you like it huh
you're so good he's just wishing he
could bite it huh
never turn down money slaying these hoes
gold trigger on the gun like
you already
never turn down money slaying these hoes
gold trigger on the gun